طيب انا عايز ابدا اني اقول حاجه
ممكن اي بني ادم
في العمود
الجامعه الامريكيه
في العام 2010
[موسيقى]
مؤسسه جمهوريه
اخوانها المؤسسه
التعليم 2013
ومش يقدر يقول لي ايه
وكام من ضمن المواد المدرسيه هنا ما
بيسمع
والدكتور او البروفيسور ساعات الكامله اول
معاه خلاص لاننا نعمل
هنا نمسك مؤسسه نشتغل عليها اه
تحليل مسجد
الحقيقه
لكن الحلقه
[موسيقى]
احسن حاجه فقط اكثر
بيذيع وجزمه بتخيط مش متشيعه الادويه لا
نعرف
الكلام ده زي بالضبط بالضبط
سادت حاجه من الهرج والمرج انا ما عارف
اشوف لكن الغالي ما هم يعني مثلا فهميني
اول ما كنت ابراهيم
حافظ الموضوع كان عنده دائما
يقول
السعاده
ماتش اهو كله 100 واحد
من البنات
بعد اذنك جدا بالنسبه لي دخل
سوبر
ممكن
اشوف الجمال
[موسيقى]
وموضوع انتهى على كده
السودان 2015
[تصفيق]
الموضوع بالنسبه
فقط
[موسيقى]
ابو محمد
تمام
لو في مصالح المستقبل
[موسيقى]
كله
شغال معاكم كويسه يا اخواننا في مصر لها
40 سنه
انا قلت لكم
اي شيء بدون اعتراف مشاه
د انا ما عندي مشكله
هيديك
مع ست شهور وياخذ
والله انا
باشيل حياتهم
مش اي مشكله اعدام
نعم
جدا جدا جدا
ايه رايك فيها مثلا
[تصفيق]
التحدي الاول
هتنطلق على البنات بعد كل
حدا
[موسيقى]
اي والله الموضوع بصراحه
تقبل
الكلام بصراحه
يلا والله
الوحيد ان الناس
في خلال اسبوع فقط
واجهت خلال 120
[تصفيق]
ههه
بدون شغل للاصحاب الموجود احساس انه في
ميلز ار سكن باص
[تصفيق]
كيف اول شيء ظهرت عندنا انواع من انواع
التعاقد اللي هي ما كانت موجوده اصلا قبل
كده في المؤسسه
جديده
للنوعيه الثانيه من عدوان عندنا ممنوعه
اللينه بالدرجه في الواقعدوا به
الحقيقه
جدا لاننا تحقيق لا يكون
اتفقنا اعرف شنو قمت بست
البسمتها
ظروف وعملتها على الاستديشن
استنى الناس بتقبل الحاجه دي بيكون من
اللطافه يمكن انا كذلك مثلا عمل مع ان
وجدان طول اللطافه فما كنت
حاسد
لكن لسه المشاكل الموجوده المفضل الكلام
يا اخواننا احنا لا ما عايزين كده
ثاني يوم اتصل عليه
قال لي يا اخي 6
300 مكالمه بتدعي انه السكرين اكيد قالوا
الموضوع ده مبوظ لهم
ان احنا
يستخدم
فبالتالي اخواننا ان احنا هنختاروا مهم
بالاسكندريه
عايز منك كلمه ياخذ بتاع الموضوع
300 مكالمه في يدي نزل لي عشاء
من هنا انا وصلت يا جماعه انه المسابح ما
كانت
مثلا كان عباره السلام
اي حاجه في النهايه ده ان الناتج الطبيعي
لتعريف حاولنا بدخل الجلسه الجديده
ظهر
بالطريقه دي طيب الحاجه بعدها
الحل الوحيد بعد ايام الدراسه
لازم نعالج الانسان موجود
استاذ مصطفى لازم
مين
رؤيه ماب الرئيسيه لهذا الموسم
طيب
عباره عن الحاله السحري كثير لانهم يا
اخواننا اي زول بعيد
الخبره دائما
لا الموضوع زي ما احنا كنا
نض
يف معرفه نحن قاعدين نت
علم
بالعكس ده بيحصل نوع من
يعني
التضامن مع بعض وبالعكس ظهرت عندنا حاجات
ثانيه
[موسيقى]
صار عندنا شيء بلونطات
لطيفه والوان في مؤسسه
والريحه اللطيفه حتى المكان ما كان فيها
في مصر بيجموا ان احنا اخواننا عايزين
نكون معنا في ناس
طيب الحال ماشي بالطريقه لطيفه جدا في اخر
[تصفيق]
العام
يا حبيبي
دخلناها من الدعم
دي كانت اول دخلت هذه الموظف
وتعب شديد جدا
مهما كانت لم يا اخواننا
المدير خمرت في راسي قاعده
تنفق على 7 سنه واصبحا على عبد الله
النقطه الثانيه اللي انا عايز اقوله يا
اخواننا خلي
ك لانه لو ما كنت واث
ق في ما تعملي شيء يا اخواننا انا بطني
انه الدوله
دي اكيد انا شخصيا
سبع مرات شربتها انا وانا شخصيا قدمت
لانه الق
صه ده واسوا الظهر انا شخصيا من الباب ما
اقدر
صامت لان هو مخترع كمان عايز اعمل تحاليل
حياه الرسول صح والحمد لله بعدكم ما بعث
سنه واحده جديد في عقليات يدعم 16
50 بعمليات ال 40 سنه قدرت انا غيرتها
الوقفيه بتاعي صح هنرجع الفيديو ده
الوطن الوطن
العربيات 1920
فاهم
اننا
ممكن دعم ممكن نغير
في مظلانه نغير
[موسيقى]